[Music]
the Sochi Winter Olympics ended last
Sunday and the Russians are still
crowing about their victory
you see they won the most gold medals
and the most medals overall but it got
me fill you there I don't know having
some sort of a patch thing here oh I
think it's an audio guy on the feed okay
that is incredibly annoying alright
anyway as I was saying at Sochi the
Russians won the most medals but the
real story Marty just called me he said
he could hear me on the feed hey whoever
you are if someone says they can hear
you on the feed maybe you should stop
talking something's messed up I'm gonna
you know they'll try and take the AES
output and just run it through the 571
let me just try that right now hey okay
all right problem solved good you had me
worried there for a second hey you know
we should probably have Marty check the
true peak settings on the base EQ filter
yeah and ask him why we don't have a
true bypass what good is a multiwave
distortion pedal without a true bypass
this is unbelievable I know why can't we
get a distortion pedal with the true
Biden point I mean I said you know Marty
just called he says I'm actually still
on the feed hey Conan says you're still
on the feed too maybe you need to run
your source to the DNS 1500 first yeah
okay
for God's sakes how many of you guys
tried disconnecting the SPX nine ninety
running the feed through a multi-channel
peak programmed analyzer taking the root
mean square voltage the output
reconnecting via the multi-channel audio
digital interface good a deity a
converter set up with us for decibels
you know some guy just had an idea
so I'm gonna give that a shot worked
okay I'm very sorry about that ladies
and gentlemen I was trying to say
something it's been in the news it's
about Sochi the medal count what
happened was that I tried the XLR m3 pin
connector
monkey good yeah you know it said it had
a 120 degree angle acceptance but I
wasn't able to get that you know what
the 48 volt power converter
[Applause]
[Music]
I always go with people